thank you for your kind introduction
the title of my presentation is ips
cells derived and patient-derived
intestinal organoid for gastrointestinal
research
for today's agenda i will first give a
brief overview of organoids what they
are their advantages and limitations
then i will introduce you to our
ips derived codon organoid system and
how to differentiate
human ips cells to colon organoids
i will also discuss the applications
that can be used with these coding
organoids
lastly i will go over our
patient-derived intestinal organoid
biobank
so what are organoids organoids are
self-organizing three-dimensional
structures derived from either pure
potent stem cells or from
from primary tissue with the ability to
recapitulate
some of the spatial architecture and in
vivo function of organs
recent years 3d organoids have emerged
as an important tool for disease
modeling
over the last several years the number
of scientific publications
utilize organized organoids has grown
exponentially
organoid organoids are different from
spheroid culture in that spheres or 3d
cultures
derived from established monolayer cell
line and thus
may lack the complex cellular
heterogeneity and
architecture of the tissue of origins
there are advantages of using organoid
because they are derived from patient
tissues or stem cells they contain
mixture of cell type and does mimic the
complex in
vivo cellular heterogeneity of the
primary organs
they can be frozen and expanded over
multiple passages
biobanks may be created from them
finally they can be genetically
manipulated using crispr technology
there are also some limitations for
organized culture as well
isolation and culture of organoids from
primary tissues may require experience
and training
while protocol to differentiate ips cell
to organize are lengthy and complex
they also require expensive factors such
as responding
when 3a and noggin for culturing these
factors
may require a lot qualifications to
reduce for
reduced variability between lots
organoids can also be variable
shape and size thus making it difficult
to implement
them in high throughput test screening
assays
typically organoids are derived from
either embryonic or
induced periopolin stem cells are from
adults
stem cells resected or biopsy from
organs
both types have the unique capacity to
self-renew and differentiate
which are the defining features of stem
cells the left schematic shows the
generation of an
adult stem cell derived also known as
patient-derived organoid
from primary tissue biopsies tissues are
dissociated into single cell suspension
and then embedded in an extracellular
matrix such as
maker gel and grown in the presence of
specific growth factors
to direct cell differentiations these
specific
growth factors may vary depends on the
tissue
being cultured the right schematic
depicts the generation
of a pure potent stem cells or ips
derived organoids from 2d stem cell
cultures
that mature into spheroids these
spheroids may be embedded in an
extracellular matrix
and grown in the presence of specific
growth factors to
the tissue of interest
to circumvent some of the limitations
mentioned earlier melapo sigma has
developed our human code and organized
system
the system includes kits to allow
researchers to take the human ips cells
and through a stepwise process
differentiate prior proteins themselves
to
definitive endoderm and then to handgun
endoderm and eventually
into conan organoids the entire process
takes around 48 days
the media kits are chemically defined
they do not
contain serum and are subject to
stringent quality control
our differentiation media kits have been
validated on two human ips
lines one from human foreskin
fibroblasts and the other from pbmc
derived human ips
cells we've shown that the resulting
coding organoids express
appropriate markers indicative of
multiple cell types
found in the codon including goblet
cells enterocyte
tenant cells and enteroendocrine cells
our coordinate organoids can be crowd
preserved
propagated and expanded over multiple
passages
and for researchers who may not want to
go through the lengthy differentiation
process
we also offer crowd preserved human ips
derived coding organoids
and the expansion media the coordinates
can be
used for a variety of applications
including gi
absorption and toxicity screens of all
drugs
metabolism infectious disease modeling
and microbiome research
step one is to start with a high quality
human ips cells
grown in feeder-free conditions if your
ips cells are not
already in fetal free conditions we
recommend that you transition them to
fetal free culture
for several passages before starting
ips cells should express high level of
pure protein
markers such as r4 12-1-60
and fc-4 make sure your ips cells are
undifferentiated and by
by having compact colonies with distinct
borders and well-defined
edges as shown differentiated cells must
be cleaned off
under a dissecting microscope before
initiation of differentiation
once your ips cells have been determined
to be of high quality
thought dissociate ips cells to single
cells using echomax and culture
overnight in the presence of rock
inhibitors
the next day cell should be about
approximately 85 to 90 percent
confluence start definitive endoderm
differentiation by adding
definitive endoderm induction media from
day 1 to day 3
is a 3-day induction process change
media every 24 hours
on day 4 one of the wealth is sacrificed
for co-staining with cxcl4 and stock 17
to test for the differentiation
efficiency for definitive endoderm by
flow cytometry
double positive for cxcl4 plus 17 must
be greater than 90
before proceeding to the hindgut and the
term differentiation
to analyze by flow for the percentage
uh percent purity of your definitive
endoderm
start with an unstained sample and
create quadrant
a gate with the unstained sample then
use this gauge to determine the percent
positive of cxcl4 alone
and then soft17 alone and most
importantly the cxer4
plus 17 double positive as you can see
the percentage purity of
the xcl4 plus 17 population is greater
than 90 percent
if for some reason the percent purity of
cxcl4 plus soft 17 double positive
is below 90 percent and the possible
causes are
you're starting ips cells are not of
high quality
we recommend to check for pure potency
for
r4 12-1 that's 12-1-60 and the
sc-4 markers also make sure that your
ips cells are pure and undifferentiated
before initiating differentiation
also your ips cells on day one is either
too sparse or too confluent
make sure your ips cells are completely
single dissociated before counting
because clumps can affect accuracy in
cell count
on day 4 to day seven begin hindgut
endoderm differentiation by adding
heineken endothermic induction media to
the culture every 24 hours
on day eight sacrifice one well for the
flow analysis
for the expression of the hein gun
endoderm marker cd x2 before proceedings
percent cd x2 positive must be greater
than 60 percent
the image on the lower left show the
appearance of spheroids on day six of
spheroids are more abundant on day seven
and day eight
the dot plot on the right is an example
of our flow analysis
for the expression of cdx2 on day eight
of differentiation the higher percentage
of cdx2 the better
if the percentage of cdx2 is below 60
the possible causes are again your ips
cells are not of high quality
and also your ips cells on day one is
either too sparse or too confluent
on day eight transitions to 3d
grow human colon expansion media
change media every day
every other day until day 20. on day 20
dissociate into single cell and embed in
25 microliter growth factor reduce major
gel dome
we recommend doing a 1 to 50 and 1 to
100 dilutions
first to determine the optimal number of
cells to embed
aim for approximately ninety percent
occupancy in each dome
the image on the lower left show the
appearance of hindgut spheroids on day
12
of differentiation more high gut spirits
are present on day 20.
an example image is shown of single
cells from day 20 embedded into 25
microliter
growth factor reduce major geodome in 24
well plate
the appearance of coated organoids with
buttings are observed on day 12
in the dome as shown on the image to the
right
our ips derived coding organoids can be
passage over a long period of time
the image on the left is the first 12
days
in growth factor reduced major gel dome
designated as passive
zero note that the developing
organelles are not mature yet but they
do have much blooding
but but they do not have much butting
day 42 is day 10 of passage 1.
organoids are bigger and have multiple
budding
day 52 is day 10 opacity 2 and organoids
have complex structures and budding
at this stage these organoids are
considered to be mature
day 428 is day 9 of passage 37
and it serves as an example that our ips
derived coding organized can be passed
at many times
the organelles still have the complex
duty structures and budding
we recommend passage every 10 to 12 days
using organo dissociation reagent
do not exceed 12 days before passaging
on the first two days of every passage
rough inhibitor is added to enhance
viability
thereafter rock inhibitor is not
necessary
organoids can be preserved in colon
expansion media plus 10
dmso or organized freeze media
it's important too it is important to
monitor your organized culture daily
as you can see the organoid looks
translucent on day 10 and day 12.
from day 14 onward organoid looks less
translucent and centers look very dark
and dense
thus we determined that the optimal
passage time is
10 to 12 days preferably 10 days
if you go the past 14 days the organoids
start to form dark necrotic balls
that start to disintegrate at the edges
as shown by the red arrows
for those that do not prefer to go
through the differentiation protocol
we also offer crowd-preserved human ips
derived coding organized and expansion
media
our crowd-preserved 3d grow human
coating organoids contain about 24
hundred organelles provided sufficient
for 12 times 25 microliter dome in 24
well played
each dome has about 60 to 70 or
percent organized occupancy two days
after thought
as seen on the image to the left by day
seven there are about 90
organized in each dome we recommend
passaging at conservative
one to three ratio until become more
familiar with culturing organoids
if by day 10 you don't see 90 occupancy
you can still salvage by passaging at a
more conservative one to two ratio
here are some examples and
recommendations
from 70 to 90 percent occupancy passage
at one to three intel
become more familiar with culture and
organoid
from forty to seventy percent occupancy
passage at one to two
from 30 and below recede back into the
same number of dome
we characterize our ips derived coding
organoids with these markers on the list
by whole mount
immunofluorescent staining the four that
are highlighted in red are the conan
specific markers
they are carbonic anhydrous ii carbonic
anhydrase
four mucin5b and sap b2
and they are all expressed in our ips
derived coding organoids in addition to
the rest on the list
here are the icc data of the stainings
they are positive for the colon specific
markers
calcium carbonic anhydrase ii
carbonic anhydrase iv and mucoin 5b
the posterior handgut cdx2 marker is
expressed along with lgr5
which is the stem cell marker expressed
at the base of the crypts
also positive are ep xv2 scale 1
mucin 2 et hearing which is an
epithelial marker
and tph-1 and enteroendocrine cell
marker
to confirm the expression of gala4 and
snap b2
of our ips throughout colon organoids we
stain alongside
a patient-thrive called an organoid line
and found that both expresses set b2 and
gata4
both markers are expressed in the
nucleus and they overlay
with with that b
we found that gala4 mrna is expressed in
the stomach
duodenum small intestine and coding from
bulk sequencing data on protein
atlas.org as shown here
we get asked often whether ips derived
choline organoids
expressed by mention which is a
mesenchymal cell marker
we tested for the expression of
dimension by flow cytometry
using our human ips cells and mcs7 cells
as a negative controls
and mdamb231 as positive control
results show that our ips derived
choline organoids are negative for
badminton
we recently sequenced our human ips
derived coded organoid
and a patient-derived coded organelle
line along with our ips cells
by rnac here is a bi-clustering heat map
that shows the expressing profile of the
top 30 differentially
expressed genes in both ips derived and
patient derived conan organoid
their expression patterns are very
similar to each other that
are very different from the ips cells
besides the top three differentially
expressed genes
both ips derived called an organoids and
patient-derived choline organoids share
similar expression trends of some of the
colon
genes are shown in this graph
next i want to shift our attention to
the cytotoxicity
drug screen application data using our
human ips derived coding organoids
for the cytotoxicity drug screen seven
compounds
with well-known effects along with three
mercenary compounds were tested
screening was performed on four day old
four days all organoid
four replicas were performed with a
concentration ranging from 10 nanomotor
to 300 micromotor
dmso was used as a vehicle control
metformin a drug used to treat type 2
diabetes
which is known to be well tolerated was
used as a control as well
cell viability was assay after 72 hour
of treatment
protocol is fairly simple and is also
detailed on a
sigma website so basically harvest
domes and passage according to protocol
the 10 microliter
major gel domes into 96 well plates in
100 microliter expansion media plus rock
inhibitor
incubate at 37 degrees celsius
in the presence of 5 co2 for 3 days on
day 4
replace the media with the compound
and then measure cell viability at 72
hours later
these are the dose response cyber
toxicity results of different drugs on
our ips derived called an organoids
flavorperiodo was the first cdk
inhibitor in human clinical trials
it is known to induce programs without
death
its toxic effect on our ips drug called
an organoids is consistent with
expectation
his fitness and loperamide also exit
exhibit toxic
effect as expected for metformin
we do not observe any apparent cytotoxic
cytotoxicity even at 750 micromotor
this is consistent with expectation
to the left are examples of drugs which
have no
apparent cytotoxicity effects on our
coding
organoids they are paracetamol training
tylenol and ketoprofen
a non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drug
that is used to treat arthritis
and allocatron training
lotonix which is used to treat diarrhea
and severe irritable bowel syndrome
of the drug tested seven of nine
compounds would
conform with expectations ongoing
clarifications of additional gi talks
compounds
is required to determine predictive
value of this gi talks model
for high throughput screens it is
important to have consistent
welterweight reproducibility
in this experiment we dissociate colon
organoids into single cells
and plated them at 25 000 cells per dome
five days after seeding we see that each
well contains dome with similar number
of viable cells
single cells dissociated choline
organoids will reassemble into 3d
organoids
as shown in the image on the right there
is side variability within wells but
well to well consistency observed
different plating density are possible
thus providing flexibility
in when to initiate experimental
treatment
we also performed forskolin induced
swelling essay
on our ips derived coding organoids and
found that
the cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulator
genes is functional the ips derived
coded organoids
in the left image do not swell in the
absence of
foscilin when 10 microliter of fosulin
is added
to the culture swelling is observed
starting at 3.5 hours and onwards
a 36 hour time lapse of this is
available on our website
we now offer a comprehensive biobank of
highly texturized tissue derived human
gastrointestinal organoids from normal
and disease patients
which have been developed by researchers
at the university of michigan center
for gastrointestinal research there will
be a total of 58 pdos derived from the
stomach the duodenum
the idiom of the small intestines colon
and rectal samples
17 of which has recently launched and
rna-seq data for each is available
normal and disease derived from codon
adenoma
ulcerative colitis and crohn's disease
are also on the list
these pdos are of low passage number and
highly viable upon
thought all our culture in our optimized
3d grow
lwr and conditioned media
here are the images of a few of our pdos
five are from normal tissues and the one
on the lower right hand corner
is from colorectal adenoma tissues
here is a detailed list from our webpage
showing the age
thanks organ and whether the pdos are
from normal or
all disease tissues the first 17 in blue
again are recently launched
here is the characterization data by icc
of a patient derived called an organoid
line
it's possible positive for cold and
specific markers
the carbonic anhydrase ii carbonic
anhydrase 4 and museum 5b
the posterior hindgut cdx2 marker is
expressed along with lrg5 which is the
stem-cell marker expressed at the base
of the crypt
it is also possible for sca1 e-cadherin
and epithelial marker and tph-1
and endocrine enteroendocrine style
marker
now i would like to briefly discuss the
salt covale2
and its effect on the gut enterocytes
recent publications have shown that the
intestines may present another viral
target organ
studies have reviewed that salt cover 2
receptor
angiotensin converting enzyme 2
h2 for short is highly expressed in the
small intestine
let's first look at the general
structure of sarco coronavirus
figures 1a depicts the structure of
sarcoid 2 varion with the main
set of glycoproteins of the four
essential glycoprotein
it is the s or the spike glycoprotein
that binds to the host
cells a2 receptors that allow for viral
entry
because one b shows a linear map of the
spike glycoprotein its n-terminus s1
contain the receptor binding domain
which is required for binding of the
host h2 receptor
the c-terminus s2 unit contains a
functional element required for fusion
it also contains a transmembrane domain
for membrane anchoring and a cytoplasmic
cell
for appropriate intracellular
trafficking
there are two routes of viral entry into
the whole cell
one is by receptor-mediated endocytosis
initiated by the binding of the viral
spike glycoprotein to the h2 receptor
on the whole cell the virus then ends up
ends up in the endosome where the low ph
level activate cadets in l
adapts an l then activates the viral
glycoprotein and facilitate viral
membrane fusion resulting in the release
of its genetic material
out of the endosome and into the
cytoplasm alternatively the spike
glycoprotein can be creased by the
surface protease on the whole cells
called tempus 2
and this can lead to the direct fusion
of the viral
membrane and the plasma membrane
resulting in the release of the bottle's
viral genetic material into the
cytoplasm
our patient-derived duodenum organoid
expresses
both h2 and temperature ii markers
thus it may be suitable for use as an
experimental model
for the study of coronavirus infection
and its biology
besides our human intestinal organoids
we also offer general organoid qualified
reagents such as
our lwn condition media supplement for
culturing pdos
our ausponding one conditioned media
supplements
we also offer organo dissociation
reagent and our organoid freezing medium
we also have our responding one
expression 293t cell line available for
making your own
media condition media we recently
launched our human
lung organelle system as shown here the
system consists of all of the necessary
differentiation media for generating the
true lung bug of
blood organoids we we also have our
uh uh human ips
derive anterior foregut endoderm
available for further differentiation to
mature
lung blood organoids
in summary human colon organoids can be
generated from human ips cells using our
stepwise differentiation protocol
along with alchemically defined serum
free media kits
our ips derived coating organoids can be
preserved
propagated and expanded in long-term
culture
they express appropriate markers
indicative of multiple cell types found
in the colon
they can be single-celled dissociated to
control for consistency in
organoid numbers from well to wealth for
hydro food screening
they show similar trends to that of
patient-derived cold and organoids by
rna-seq data
they can be used in cellular toxicity
drug screening
also the cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conducting regulator gene is functional
58 total gastrointestinal organoids are
available from normal
and disease tissue with low passive
number
our patient-derived duodenum organoids
express the two salt covered two
cell cellular entry markers h2 and
temperatures ii
lastly i would like to acknowledge my
colleagues on the list for making the 3d
organo product possible
i also would like to recognize our merc
healthcare in germany for the subtle
toxicity
data lastly i would like to recognize
the team
at the university of michigan center for
gastrointestinal research
for making the pdo biobank possible
thank you for your attention and i'm
looking forward to your questions